et les mamies interdit aujourd'hui ni
qu'amène on l'a découvert sur nos petits
écrans alors qu'il se déshabiller dans
une pub
peu après il rencontre madonna qui lui
fait faire un disque il en est
aujourd'hui à son deuxième album
il nous raconte tout ça dans un instant
un mannequin qui chante ça arrive mais
qui en plus compose toutes ces musiques
c'est plus rare nikam n est diffusée
sous le label d'un producteur pas tout à
fait inconnue une certaine madonna
[Musique]
qu'est ce que je peux dire sur madonna
elle m'a aidé pour mon premier disque
qui vous fasse enfin c'est elle qui a
produit le premier titre que ce travail
entre deux jours avant ma première
séance d'enregistrement
j'avais entendu parler de moi à ce
moment j'étais en amérique se sent comme
chez elle m'a appelé pour savoir si je
voulais me lancer la chanson faudra être
aussi simple que ça j'étais à los
angeles c'était en 86 on s'est vus et
déjà enregistré le morceau que l'on
connaît il n'y a pas que madonna dans la
vie
ce petit jeune homme a un sens aigu de
la famille portrait de quelques membres
de la tribu gester c'est un de mes
grands frères
une des principales raisons pour
lesquelles je fais de la musique et que
lorsque j'étais jeune on était déjà dans
un groupe il était demeure toujours un
grand guitariste baril c'est mon plus
jeune frère je me sens très proche de
barrie on a grandi ensemble et hier s'il
y avait un grand écart d'âge outre les
prêts si c'était plutôt j'ai passé la
plupart du temps avec lui à londres
beaucoup aidé et rien d'autre
c'est un peintre il a réalisé le design
de la pochette 2010 mais aussi beaucoup
aidé pour la présentation et la vidéo et
pécs
[Musique]